OFF OF RODRIGUES, AND HE
SCORES!
2-0, PENGUINS! 3-0!
LOOK AT THAT.
TALK ABOUT
CONTINUING WITH THE PASS. A LOT
PLAYERS.MAINTAIN
POSSESSION.
MARINO.
PETTERSSON WIDE OPEN.   FOR
THE FIRST TIME ON THE NIGHT.
THEY HAVEVE
TURNS IT OVER. THE
BOARD. H STICK.
HE KNOCKS THE CROSS.  DOES IT A
RINK. .
>> TRICKLING INRE HE GETS TO TH
INTO THE CORNER BY
TRIES HAS REALLY SOLD THE
LAST FIVE MINUTES HERE.
HE HAS BEEN PHENOMENAL.
THE DRAGON, AGAIN! FIGHTING HIS
INTO THE ARE
THINKING GOING BACK TO YOUR
QUESTION YOU SCORE THAT ONE GOA
CHANCES TONIGHT.
NOT AVAILABLE.
HE HANGS ONTO IT AND WAITS FOR
THE GOALTENDER TOEASY MATCHUP.
WHETHER IT IS GOING TO BE
CAROLINA.
VORACEK  WITH THE SCORE. AINST
CIRCLE THE DATES ON THE
CALENDAR.  THIRD PERIOD.
THAT IS AN ICING CALL.